this unremarkable spot in a place called
zaparisia
means a lot to the people of mario paul
it's a beacon of light in the dazzling
sunshine and it marks the end of a
horrific ordeal
it's really strong bad painful
experience
and now we need to start our life from
from the beginning
they arrive in a procession of battered
looking cars with a sign saying children
in the windows
the journey from mario paul is
relatively short
but it is a dangerous trip and some take
days to complete it
how do you feel
helena and her family have negotiated 15
russian checkpoints
but she and her granddaughter alisa are
safe
i am
you're fine okay
you've had quite an experience
today
irina and her family took six days to
get here they ran out of petrol halfway
but she couldn't spend another minute in
mariopol
i don't know really how to describe it
because
you don't know will you be alive and i
mean i don't know will your son will be
alive
oh no
one night
he said to me my son he is 10 years old
sorry
one minute
he asked me
mama will you
will i see my birthday in august or no
will i'll be alive and i
didn't know what to say to him
on the other side of the street we found
another convoy of cars hoping to make
the trip back to mario paul
the owners want to pick up family or
friends or bury those killed in the
fighting
alexander's mother lived in a building
that was hit by a shell
and he said he wasn't able to reach her
uh
it's been cold he said very cold i doubt
she's alive if i find a leg i find a leg
but i will bury her
some families bring their documents and
the clothes on their back
others like the lachenkos have brought
the business
and their business is french bulldogs
and pugs
they've got 50 of them now living in two
vans
you don't have much room back there
36 000 people have passed through this
car park along with a large family of
french bulldogs
their lives have been uprooted their
homes have been destroyed but where
there is life there is hope
john sparks sky news in zappo regia